Speaker 1: We learned late last night about
a major change to the scope of the current
New Yorker.
Attorney general's investigation into the
Trump Organization, it is now a criminal investigation,
full stop.
What started as a civil investigation into
the Trump organization is now a criminal investigation.
This is a huge deal and it at least changes
the possible path of the probe.
Now, remember that New York State Attorney
General Letitia James was already in the middle
of a civil investigation of Donald Trump's
company.
Now they are investigating the Trump organization,
quote, in a criminal capacity.
This is also hard to even keep this all straight.
This is not the same investigation that Cy
Vance Jr. is doing.
James's spokesman says this investigation
is being conducted in conjunction with the
criminal probe of Trump and the Trump organization
by the Manhattan district attorney, Cyrus
Vance.
This is the attorney general of New York.
Now, these are two criminal investigations.
Now, part of this is all thanks to Michael
Cohen, Donald Trump's former attorney, who
has said many times now that the Trump organization
misstated real estate valuations to reduce
their tax liabilities and to get better loan
and insurance terms.
The full statement from Letitia James's office
is short and it is, quote, We have informed
the Trump Organization that our investigation
into the organization is no longer purely
civil in nature.
We are now actively investigating the Trump
Organization in a criminal capacity, along
with the Manhattan district attorney.
We have no additional comment at this time,
recalled that Letitia James is the prosecutor
who went after the Trump Foundation.
Trump's now dissolved charity was ordered
to pay two million dollars to settle a lawsuit
by the AG's office, saying he misused the
Trump Foundation and its funds to benefit
his presidential campaign, as well as other
unlawful activity for more than a decade.
And the Trump Foundation agreed to pay the
fine, and they also agreed in December of
twenty eighteen to completely dissolve and
donate all remaining funds to charity.
That's the same Letitia James that got that
done, who is now investigating the Trump organization
criminally.
Trump is calling both investigations witch
hunts, which to me suggests, wow, there's
probably something here and we will see where
both investigations go.
Now, I maintain and I know some people get
mad when I say this, I maintain Trump will
see no prison time period.
There will be no handcuffed perp walk.
But the more that this builds and now it has
shifted from merely civil to criminal, the
possibility that someone goes to prison does
go up.
But almost certainly this is going to be a
massive financial burden on Trump in terms
of legal bills.
And as I've said before, these investigations,
while they're not going to put Trump in prison,
they're not they could keep Trump from running
in twenty, twenty four, which would be amazing.
It's optimistic thinking, but it very well
could quickly become a massive burden for
Trump.
And if it keeps him out of out of candidacy
in three and a half years, that would be a
great thing.
Now, there's one other aspect to this.
There are people reacting to news from this
probe and from the Cy Vance probe by saying
if it's taking this long, nothing is happening.
It's just going to peter out.
I spoke to a couple of prosecutors I know
who said, you know, from the outside, you
can't really know.
But often the longer the investigation takes,
the stronger the case is because they're uncovering
more and more wrongdoing and they want to
be really sure that the cases are ironclad
before they move forward.
Either way, it's speculative.
But the point is, it's not obvious.
It's not certain that the fact that this is
dragging with no charges yet is bad.
It's also important to remember, at least
with the Cy Vance probe, that Trump was able
to obstruct that moving forward by not providing
his tax returns for his entire presidency.
Only in the last couple of months did they
finally get a court decision that said, yes,
Trump must give Cy Vance his taxes.
So that part of the investigation has only
really now started.
It's been delayed and that could be part of
it as well.
One other really small thing, a couple of
people wrote to me and they said this is the
real reason Trump left New York.
It wasn't to avoid taxes.
It wasn't because New York wasn't good to
him because they didn't vote for him in the
presidential election.
The real reason Trump left New York was to
get away from this investigation.
I just don't think so.
No.
One, Trump is a narcissist and narcissists
have this idea that no one can touch them.
So I don't think Trump is leaving.
That doesn't make sense.
Number two, leaving New York doesn't actually
stop the investigations.
So it would be stupid in that sense.
And number three, Trump is really cheap and
really greedy.
So leaving changing residency from New York
to Florida makes a lot of sense because avoiding
taxes is completely on brand with.
Donald Trump's priority, so that's I believe
that's really the reason Trump left the investigation,
will follow him to Florida if that's what
needs to happen.
And it will.
I don't think Trump really thinks in the terms
you and I might think of something like this.
So I think it's just money.
And that's why Trump left New York, at least
as far as residency is concerned.
We'll have more on this growing multiple investigations
set now on The David Pakman Show Instagram.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
The David Pakman Show and follow me on Instagram
for the latest from my garden.
Nothing more riveting than that.
You can find me on Instagram at David Pakman.